in this morning's eye on money we are
looking at tax
filing confusion caused by the pandemic
now tax season traditionally starts in
the last week of january but this year
the irs begins
accepting and processing individual tax
returns
today now the agency says the delay is
caused by late changes
in the tax law the deadline to file is
the same though that is april 15th
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us now joe good
morning to you
a lot of different categories of filers
this year one in particular
comes to mind first 160 million
americans or thereabouts
got a stimulus payment last year is that
taxable
that is not taxable so good news right
so if you got twelve hundred dollars or
five hundred per kid
maybe you were one of the few people who
got that extra six hundred dollars at
the end of december
that's not taxable but here's what's
really important a lot of people said
they were missing
their stimulus payments or they got less
than they thought maybe they had a child
and the irs didn't know that
if that's the case for you you are going
to file your taxes and you are going to
focus on it ready for this
line 30 of your form because that's the
recovery
rebate credit if you think you are due
money
focus on that make sure you fill that
out and be sure that you get the money
you're due
all right very good to know stimulus
payments not taxable
what about the 22 million americans who
were unemployed at some point last year
and they got unemployment money is that
taxable
that is taxable unemployment benefits
whether it came through the cares act
whether it came through your state of
residence
totally taxable now some people had
withholding that's good
but on the federal level unemployment
benefits are taxable
here's something else to remember there
are actually 15
states that do not levy tax on
unemployment benefits
check to see if you're on this list
because then you might be able to avoid
it but
unfortunately unemployment is seen as
income taxes income i guess the only
good news is you didn't get taxed like
in the fica sense you didn't pay into
social security on these dollars
okay now if you were lucky enough to
keep a job many many many millions of
americans have been doing that job from
home
since basically march of last year does
that mean they can write off the portion
of their home they're using as an
office this is probably the most
frequently asked question that i got
last summer when people were filing
their taxes
for on an extension here's the deal in
2017 we had a new tax law and it
basically said
no office deduction for anyone who's an
employee if you're a w-2 wage earner
you can deduct a portion of your
residence or your rent
if you are self-employed you've got to
use
one room or a part of your house on a
regular basis
and you can't have another office
somewhere else so the rules are pretty
tight
again if you are a w-2 wage earner sorry
you paid for that stand-up desk in the
new chair all on your own
jill the irs is warning about some kind
of unemployment uh
tax scam i got a fishy call the other
day and as i was giving my zip code i go
i wonder if
i'm being scammed at this particular
moment what is what
what is the scam you're talking about
this is an awful scam it's basically
fraudsters stealing your your social
security number and
filing unemployment benefits on your
behalf
collecting those benefits you won't know
this happened
unless you get a form 1099 g from the
government
now here's the thing but this happened
to my sister she gets notified says hey
here's your form for the unemployment
benefits that you collected she goes i
was employed all of last year what
happened
you've got to notify the state you've
got to get a revision you probably
should also get
an a tax id protection from the irs when
you file an
ip protective code a pin because
this could mean your socials out there
anyway and you'd want to prevent against
fraud
with your federal returns all right
you've always got good advice
yeah we appreciate it joe really good
information not all of it bad either
thank you very much and if you have
additional questions for jill
on taxes you can head to our cbs this
morning facebook page where she will be
answering your questions directly i have
one
what if there's a studio in your
basement you do tv out of there every
now and then is that tax deductible
meet me on facebook to point out good
luck i think the answer might be
no i think so